what is up everybody i am procedure man
luigi and i like making video game
videos
i've been doing a lot of bored lens
pre-sequel legendary guides on my
channel recently
so i decided i would make a video where
everyone can come to my channel
and find all the legendary guides i've
made instead of having to sift through
all my videos
so you see if you click on any of these
guns or their titles
or weapons are the titles since we also
have grenade mods and an oz kit
you will be taken to the video
that is a guide and review of the gun so
you can find out how to get the gun and
if you want to use the gun
i decided to make this so it's easier
for people to
come to my channel and just find what
they want to find in terms of legendary
guides especially if you're not
subscribed to me
and i do appreciate if you like all this
content and you want to see more that
you subscribe
it lets me know that i should keep doing
what i'm doing so that's about it
i'm will be updating this as i get more
legendary guides so
keep on looking for my channel and enjoy
the guys
peace out
you